[Music]
hey everyone welcome to semi leads
podcast my name is dr. Ryan Rider
and on this episode we are going to talk
about big deals property compliance and
work-life balance cereal 2020 I feel
it's freaking awesome to be sitting at
you today I've got some questions I want
to ask to you today we've been friends
for quite some time and I feel really
privileged to be sitting at the
beginning of a new year finally I want
to pick your brain about what you gonna
be focusing in 2020 I know you recently
posted a video on your focuses in 22
minutes tell me a little bit on what
would happen - in Christmas now and
what's your big focuses in January and
why Genesis is a good month to be
investing in property I think January's
are brilliant month
I mean Christmastime this is how I
played it over Christmas and I even
posted this out there so everyone wants
their house to sell before Christmas or
the estate agents say well it'll be
solved by Christmas we're gonna aim [ __ ]
by Christmas everyone's hoping you'll be
solved by Christmas
when it doesn't sell you get pretty
depressed hmm and then you become very
motivated because the last thing you
want to do is stop being told well next
Christmas so what I did was just after
Christmas on Boxing Day I just looked
through all the houses that were still
available and then and then the there
was one working day in between Christmas
Day in the new year and on that one
working day when everyone else was like
what's going on and all hung go through
him stuff I'm just picking up the phone
booking shared loads of viewings and now
I've got a lot of deals in the bag going
through not all necessarily for me but
there's just some really awesome stuff
so we've got some land in stoke-on-trent
that we're looking to build on we've got
even quite a few lease option agreements
and for motivated salads negative equity
yeah which I'm working on with some of
my students so I think I love Christmas
to New Year period there's some people
that are putting on their houses brand
new in January like start January let's
put the house of the sale but the best
people to go for those people that
didn't sell in December in December that
really needed to because I've had the
house on the market for a few months and
you might think well why are they good
houses to go for because if they haven't
sold they haven't sold for a reason
maybe the houses suck no you're looking
into all
you need to say haven't sold they're
gonna be motivated I'm gonna get a
really good deal so that's kind of what
I'm being doing January really focusing
hard on the property front and it's just
it's just been a fab fabulous months so
far cool I'm interested to ask you a
little bit more about your preparation
for December because what's interesting
about we're sitting here now it's
January I can feel the energy just in
this evening's interview is that most
people are kind of only get it's the
beginning of January now most people
have not even thought about the year and
you have not I know your personal
background is that you've rested in in
December you went in a holiday I went on
a holiday before Christmas before
Christmas and now be the period between
Christmas and New Year you're already
doing property deals really kind of in
New Year phase but what's part you just
need to talk to you about now is that
because of your journey because of your
journey through property you were able
to go on a two-week holiday in Thailand
you still earned money while you're away
and I understand said this he said
genius happens in leisure time so I'm
actually quite interested find out what
thought flashes or what ideas you got
while you are on a holiday because I
think as an entrepreneur myself
sometimes you gets caught in the
business that you you must a thinking
time so how was your holiday for you the
holiday was great I mean we were in
Thailand and then after a few days we
just said let's go to Singapore for a
bit so we spontaneously jumped on a fly
I went to Singapore we stayed at the
Marina Bay Hotel which is absolutely
fabulous we probably spent about 35,000
pounds
you know over that two-week period so we
just really just let our hair down and
had great fun but you are right when
when you go away that is when you come
up with the genius idea so I've been
working on a new book with some of my
students which has just been it has just
been published and released on Amazon we
self-published it which is called I feel
this sounds awful wife forgotten what
it's called it's about our players the
title is that boring yeah that I forgot
what it's called it's something called
property I think it's called property
compliance made easy yeah it's not the
most exciting book it's not like how to
be financially free in seven days how do
you know buy low rent high but it
because everyone keeps saying to me but
what about compliance but what about
legislation so for all those people
interesting in that side of things
that's why we wrote the book
I say we I didn't want to write the book
because I find that stuff boring so I
brought in some of my students but to be
honest it's a fabulous book and I think
it's gonna really serve a lot of people
because there's so many people that are
these compliant mentors yeah
there are teaching people about how to
be compliant and they're charging a
fortune and they're wrapping people up
in red tape making it more complicated
than it needs to be so I wanted to just
set the record straight alongside I need
to give a shout out to Anthony Wilmot
Hannon Armstrong they really wrote the
book I just over you know over over saw
it and it's too great so it's been
fabulous and I've also I published that
video but I publish my business plan how
about my 20/20 plan listen I think
what's very interesting about how
because not being a details person
myself it's interesting I said that that
kind of world
bores you and and actually I think
having being spent some time with you I
think one of your greatest successes is
that you are you embrace a topic that I
talk about in my coaching and mentoring
in cetera and when I speak anyway is the
concept of Sloppy success yeah so I
always wanted to ask you this John and
what would you be or like how do you
balance the difference between sloppy
success and making sure that you are
okay but I know you know when we when we
had a crash course there's often a few
people especially left brain people who
are like yes and what about the
compliance and yes but what about this
and yes but what about that you I've
heard you say many times I was like x
y&z questions or about a B and C so have
you always been dispersed about your
first few property deals I know a lot of
people been following you for a while
might have heard the story but just the
the balance between going for something
sloppy success and moving forward in the
right direction and then making sure
you're compliant so as an entrepreneur
you're always looking for shortcuts
you're always looking to push the
boundaries so what you need is you need
to be someone who has people who can
guide you who say actually that's
illegal
guys right so if I'm always thinking of
if I'm always thinking of the reasons
why something won't work then that's
called pessimist so as an entrepreneur
you need to be a problem solver not a
problem finder but you do need to have
people in your team who can be the
pessimists who can be the problem
finders there
find a problem and then you'll say well
what's the solution to that though and
then you're pushing and you'll find out
but for me I'm always the person trying
to think of trying to push the
boundaries be creating things being an
entrepreneur rather than someone that
just because when people say you know oh
what about this and yeah but yeah but I
don't want to be a yeah but person I
want to be someone who's telling you I
can't be done and then I say there must
be a way because you know so I think I
think but at the same time if you if you
haven't got advisors if you haven't got
solicitors and people around you telling
you when you're doing something a little
bit too risky or a little bit too sloppy
then that's not good either so the
balance is be crazy
step out take massive action be be a
dream like a kid and take massive action
like a as if you cannot fail I think
that's so important property also to
mention is that had someone say this to
me other day when you hardly ever hear
this statement from anyone I wish I'd
never bought that property ten years ago
when when have you ever heard anyone say
that I've never heard and never I've
never heard it either and and I think
when it comes to property specifically
you know fortune does favor the brave in
some way shape or form so that balance
between and I think it's a nice topic
because so many people specific in our
crash courses there's always that yes
but what about compliance and yes but
what about this my lesson from it and my
properties is that you'll never know
everything when it comes to compliance
you'll never know everything when it
comes to the rules and regulations and
that's why solicitors exist and that's
why and if you did then you'd be broke I
know because you do be or you just be a
solicitor hmm so yeah 100% and I think
that I wrote the book or had the book
written because I wanted to set the
record straight because there's so much
nonsense said around compliance because
people just make up rules that aren't
even there because they the thing is
most people his thing like if someone
said to me hey Samuel can you teach me
to do a podcast and let's say I didn't
want them to do a podcast because I saw
them as competition I don't work like
that but let's say yes my inclination
will be to say oh wow these cost a lot
these equipment it's really hard
takes a lot of practice you can't you
know you've got to pay your guests
you've got a and I'm gonna start saying
stuff that might not even be true
because I want to put them off in the
exact same way that's what people are
doing property they say you know and
they say oh it's really hard there's
complaint and inmate stuff up it's
something even true and and the reason
that they do is either because they
don't want you to do it because they are
they see you as a threat or because they
don't want you to do because they're
trying to protect you guess what my
incarnation as a multi-millionaire
property investor and trainer and
YouTube inspirer is I actually want
people to do it so I'm gonna make it
seem simple because it is simple but
also because complexity is the thief of
execution so that's where I'm coming
from so I wrote the book because I
wanted to just say look this is
everything there is about compliance
yeah I think it's important I think I
think it's fantastic you've done it it's
not kind of a love of yours but you knew
that the marketplace needed people
needed it people were asking for it yes
I said before sometimes for certain
personality types that getting that
information is the bridge to help them
overcome that fear yeah I know that it
was like me in you I don't want to be
stubborn I don't want to say I'm not
going to talk about it because you don't
need to know it yeah I'll talk about it
and in the book we talk about literally
compliance for tenants how to be a
landlord that's be a deal sorcerer rent
to rent lease optional agreements
accountants accounting how to save money
on tax like everything all of these
questions that normally I go come on
dude just pick up the phone and find a
deal all of these Nikoli questions
around compliance and tax and laws and
regulations are in the book core awesome
everyone needs to get the book I told
you to read the book you did today
of course well here's the thing is even
the properties and the same votes as
anyone who's gone for it in the
beginning there's so many properties
that I've done where I have lied so
heavily on my legal team and my team
their army to do it but you know getting
that extra information as I say if it
exists and I know from someone who's in
the game some amazing piece of content
that everyone should read and even if
you only learn three or four new things
in the book they're made it's worth it
listen man I always tell about a story
about one of the properties that I
rented it was a commercial property
there was one sentence one sentence in
the contract that cost us 35,000 pounds
one sentence was the same
the sentence was that it was a clause in
the contract that said you you sign the
lease on the basis and this was for
commercial property on the basis that
the change of use needed to happen if
you didn't get change of use then the
contract became null and void and you
went your separate ways but you paid the
deposit in the mean time so he paid 35
grand deposit for the place and look and
the clause in the contract was best
endeavours okay now there's been a
famous court case I think Sainsbury's or
one of those big companies took another
and took another firm to court for it
and eventually someone won for the first
time ever and best endeavours is like
how long is a piece of string so if for
instance let's say you sign the lease
and then and then the the counsel come
back and say no we're actually not going
to give you planning permission to run
this medical facility here what that
means is that you can now part ways with
the landlord at the contract and they
should pay you back your deposit however
if it's got the clause based endeavours
in there they may pick up and how long's
a piece of strings first I will try I
will try it but they said well the
contract said based never so we don't
think you tried hard enough because you
may have said you wanna get the contract
back in 24 hours and you only got it
back in 48 yeah it's whatever they're
and they kept and they and they and they
knew they had a sort of a bet on they
kept that deposit yeah so if you read
them table for that just that one oh I
bet you would never be caught out on
that again listen that's my tuition it's
like my tuition to be able to teach it
now yeah is that so it's kind of a the
price you have to pay long said almost
said either you'll pay for education or
life will make you pay either way you're
going to pay at some point yeah so that
was a 35k lesson for us one sentence
when it comes to compliance listen man I
really wanted to talk to you a little
bit about and you know when you go down
your property journey you kind of got to
past in the beginning it stick along
with single-layer to stick along with
slightly deals that are gonna I know
when I started my property journey
because I was doing relatively while in
business when I first started the whole
single net world was sometimes not as
appealing as I got a bit blindsided by
the fact that maybe the cash flow was
quite low and and and sometimes that
stopped me from ticking along and I'm
just so interested to ask you a little
bit more about you did 29 property deals
last year yeah I was involved involved
in 29 property deals last year and that
is phenomenal by anybody's standards but
one of your big realizations or focuses
on 20/20 that I've had spoken to you
about is doing bigger deals yeah our pre
framed us by saying I recently had
dinner with a very successful
entrepreneur and here's a publicly
listed company turns over 250 million
dollars a year and I said to him at
dinner you know what do you [ __ ] what
are you doing at the moment and he said
to me he's building a hotel and
conference facility in Singapore and to
which I followed up and said wow that
must be so much work and I'll never
forget what he said back to me he said
big project little project same work
yeah and that we've had conversations
about that so tell us a little bit about
that focus for you and give us some
ideas what you mean when you say you're
gonna focus on you taking a slightly
different focus in 2020 but give us some
ideas so what okay firstly let me just
preach from this as well
yeah when you starting out in property
you're always gonna make mistakes and
one your first few deals even if you've
been on the programs and you've got the
training you're gonna make mistakes it's
going to be mistakes with the debt law
is gonna be mistakes with the builders
with the tenants with the agreements and
it might not be mistakes that are gonna
[ __ ] you but you're gonna make
mistakes so it makes sense when you're
starting out to start with smaller deals
so maybe get a single leg get a bit of
landlord experience then get a couple of
HMOs maybe then buy a property refurb it
and then maybe take a pub and turn it
into flats but start small because
you're gonna make mistakes it's better
to make mistakes on a small deal for a
hundred thousand pound house that
remember steaks on 100 million pound
house and now dr. Jeff in there quickly
I look back at that time where I didn't
a tick along really earning my early my
property journey at the 50k deals the
30k deals six I look back and I wish I
had yeah because at the time you know
that look that's smaller cash flow you
know but I didn't
I just I look back now I got a man I
should have ticked along and I was and I
was looking at the bigger deals already
when I should have just take so long yes
that's one of my regrets but saw
pre-frame with with that so when I looks
at my 2019 spreadsheets of how much
money that I'd made for my property
business because I don't as you know I
don't take a salary from my training
business that's mission so my property
business I was thinking the 80/20 rule
80% of the money has come from 20% of my
properties that I've bought and those
20% of the properties that have bought
has been big deals now the interesting
thing is this 80% of the workload had
come from from it's just like small so
from the small deals so I'd spent so
much more time and energy on the small
bills but then I'd make so much more
money on the big deals and I just and I
think the reason was as well because
because when you start valuing your time
a lot when you're doing a small deal the
solicitor process signing the paperwork
but I can't even be bothered to sign the
paperwork and talk to this list and talk
to the mortgage broker and talk to the
estate agent and for a house there's a
hundred grand hmm it's like well if I'm
actually gonna bill bill through the
business my hourly rate it makes the
project suddenly so much Latin but the
profit so much less yeah grows on the
big projects I can afford because the
money is so much better I can afford to
pay absolutely experts and specialists
like we've got we've got a guy Ben yeah
who's on six-figure salary plus is also
a partner in in that leaves so which is
which is our construction company so
with then I'm thinking I can't ask Ben
to go and do stuff on the small deals
but yeah I can't afford there's a
best-of-five isn't just the time to
reward ratios not just right so if I
can't afford to get these egg players
like Ben and some of my team to deal
with the little stuff who's gonna do the
little stuff my wife made me and it just
got to the point right and I spoke to
Grant Cardone I've got a credit card
home because when I met him last year in
July and we've got several meetings
books as well he just said to me dude
you playing to two small of
and I think the reason that happened was
because I these little small bills and
even the HMOs and these these properties
because they were working so well for me
and I was making money off them they
were going up in value
I became financially free off them I was
thinking well this has always worked for
me so I was just stick to what I know
works but then actually if I want to be
a billionaire if I want to impact a
billion people it just makes sense to
play a bigger game so now I'm do big
deals I was also lending money to people
I was like given I was giving money to
people like I gave out over a million
pounds just last year to my students and
some of my colleagues just in hard cash
just for them to invest and I thought if
ik fixed return on investment about 15
16 percent and I was like oh well
there's no work for me but actually it's
no work for me anyway because I've got
such good systems or such a good team
why not invest it properly myself stop
being lazy
stop being apathetic stop being
complacent think bigger and and if I'm
making so much money on these big deals
now why not why not push the push the
boat a little bit more so I still love
the small deals and I'm still gonna but
what's our context you've been do part
of 10 years of 10 years now yeah so like
anyone watching this you know that's
where you grew into a massively
successful property on top and year was
the brain butter stuff you might not all
the small tears all these for 10 years
and I would never poopoo it on my side
oh don't do that no I wish I wish I'd
done more that in the beginning phases
yes I probably got a bit blindsided by
the bigger deals but I could have ticked
along at a point in my career it's kind
of that other question there that's both
you know listen if you've got 20 grand
in the bank and you work in 9 to 5 and
you want to become financially free then
that's one thing but if you've got half
a million and you want to create massive
wealth then maybe look at do big deals
yeah got it
I recently introduced to a concept and
it kind of shook me when I heard it for
the first time and someone was like
first of all you will all know the
concept of what got you guys not going
to get you there so taking over with
that and there's a time a place to be
consistent and keep
doing a thing you're doing but someone
said this to me said said Ryan sometimes
your key to success is to stop trying
harder and house took I took a second to
think about he's like sometimes the
thing you can only try hard anything
sometimes the model if you're trying
harder for your next steps is a is maybe
got its limits
so simply trying harder at the thing
you've been doing for the last whatever
will only take you so far sometimes
about changing up your strategy a little
bit not just trying harder at something
yeah changing it up completely and I was
like stop trying hard all the time it's
like a bit of a you working so hard in
that on that that helps the wheel you
know everything right what will make you
financially free will not make you a
millionaire got it what will make you a
millionaire will not make you a
billionaire so you want to become
financially free there's a set of rules
that you have to follow hmm and then
once you've done that you need to learn
some new rules to be a millionaire and
then once you've learned that you need
to learn some new rules to be a
billionaire now I'm at the latter stage
I became financially free by 21 I became
a millionaire by 25 now I'm 28 29 and in
a few months now I'm like I want to be a
billionaire by the time I'm 40 now is it
gonna happen I can't say for sure am I
gonna make mistakes with the big deals I
can't that you have course but that's
where I am that's that's my game right
now yes I love it I love that you said
them there's a set of rules to become
financially free there's a set of rules
to become a millionaire I think
sometimes people over complicate that
and they think like you hear the set of
rules from a trusted source and then
people try over complicate it and that
you know I love the saying you can be
right or you can be rich you can't be
both and sometimes like when you know
it's like to be in the training world
where there's a set of rules that work
for you just do the thing that works as
opposed to recreate the wheel all the
time so tell me about your influences
now for your next steps to become a
billionaire which you've been very open
about so you've put it out into the
universe
yeah what are some and where there's
people you have to follow or steps you
have to take I know you've mentioned a
few now you guys are gardening is yeah
for sure well after the last year
spending time with Robert Kiyosaki
grant cut down some of these super
wealthy people what I realized was that
they all use other people's money got it
they all be with other people's money it
was something that I've all
being a little bit uncomfortable with in
the past because I kind of thought well
I don't want to use it the people's
money because I've got my own mmm but
actually what about both mmm and what
got me started in the first place
and how I started out was by using 20
grand from my grandma right so why now
would I be like oh I don't want to do
that anymore
and also when there's people in in in in
in in in Singapore with hundreds of
millions of pounds and celebrities that
I've got millions of pounds that don't
really know what to do with it and a
saying to me hey Sammy what would you if
you got any ideas before I would say to
them yeah come on the crash course but
but not being funny but some of these
multimillionaires celebrities that they
might not have the time you know I've
been working with a lot of premier
footballers I've just been on the phone
yesterday it's someone who you a star
premier football player
multi-millionaire like for him coming to
a crash course I used to be like what's
the problem man just get down you need
to do whatever it takes but now I'm
thinking maybe I need to be able to find
a way of also helping those people
there's so many there's so many
footballers who are multimillionaires
who were 22 who are blowing all of their
money who could any minute have an
injury and then suddenly they'll be
pushing boxes and Sainsbury yeah with
depression like if I know how to help
them out and also it's gonna help get me
to a billionaire Zig Ziglar says help
other people get what they want you'll
get what you want so now I'm doing some
partnering I'm venturing and I'm letting
them invest in the big deals which is
also scaling my net worth up as well I'm
gonna think that something's a grant
cardone
Robert Kiyosaki all of these guys do and
now I'm thinking more if I want to stay
a millionaire then fine but if I want to
become a billionaire I need to start
doing this I need to because because if
you want to if you want to make it a
billion pounds you've got a impact a
billion people you've got to help more
people so I think it's just opening up
more doors helping more types of
different types of people so yeah
because I know you've had these
opportunities flowing your way for a
while yes yes yes but what was the shift
for you the shift was for you to the
play a bigger game is that you had to
say yes to some of these opportunities
so as well that I mean the fact that
I've been doing big deals for the last
couple of years now myself like I might
not be ready for it a few years ago now
I'm in a position where I've got
full-time Chartered Surveyors valuers
cost managers builders on your team um
why do you seem no subcontracted you
really got your your Power Team no one's
got better a better Power Team in
property than me right now in the UK
here no one's got better connections
than me right now in the UK so I've got
that in one way and when people say to
me as well now like someone who's your
solicitor who's your semi who's your
who's your it's a bit difficult because
before I just came and this is my sister
this is my broker but now I'm thinking
now I've got different set of team
they'll charge you a thousand pounds an
hour you don't want to use them I know
and I'll recommend different types of
people because when I was growing up and
I wasn't in deals I was finding people
from being high networking I was getting
people you know small teams now I'm
working with big companies and
organisations so when I get someone
that's buying their first deal that says
you know awesome you use it for your
break it's like yeah this is a different
game right now so now I've created this
big power team for big deals to not let
other people tap into that would be
would be a shame awesome listen we're
the beginning of a decade yeah we just
finished the decade been a good decade
for you yeah massive ten years in
property you if you had said yourself
ten years ago
that you'd be where you are right now
what would you have said to yourself
that I don't think I would have believed
it cool
so now take that into the next ten years
where would you like to be in ten years
time well I want to be a millionaire by
the time I'm 40 I'm now 29 soon so by 30
23 I want to be I want to be pushing a
millionaire I also want to be and the
thing is some people might say well I
didn't want to be a billionaire I
remember when I when I started out you
say ten years ago ten years ago I was 19
all I wanted was financial freedom if
you said to me ten years ago you want to
be a millionaire
that'll be a minute I'd wanna be
followed me for it but then when I
became financially free I wanted to be a
millionaire why because I wanted to push
myself not because I wanted the million
pounds in my bank but because of who I
knew that I would become in being able
to make a million pounds card it's the
exact same thing is going on now man
yeah I want to be a billionaire no
because I don't want to look at however
many zeros in the bank I'm not
interested in that what I want is I want
to be become the kind of person that can
add that much value to society into the
planet that I deserve to be a
billionaire if you gave me a billion
pounds now from the lottery you would
actually it will be almost like me
looking at everything I can't wait to
climb it come on let's go team and then
someone just skipping me up on a zip or
a helicopter I would feel cheated if you
gave me a bit I don't want you to anyone
to give me a billion I want to earn it
and I want to become someone that can
manager yeah I understand and it's
interesting you know that concept of
becoming that person over time has been
a huge influence of my and not only my
property journey but my business journey
is I truly believe that business is the
greatest personal development program of
all time yeah sure because there you can
have so many challenges within business
doesn't matter it doesn't matter when
it's it it's when it hasn't happens not
if and through those challenge you learn
so much about yourself yeah so if that
is your next ten years and your lessons
from the last ten years my wife night
every single December sit down and we
look back at the previous year and go
well ones
what were some of our unexpected ones
what would you like to do more of in the
next year or less of in the next year if
I to say to you on the last decade what
do you think you should what some of the
things you should do less of in the next
decade to achieve your goals or more of
in the next decade to achieve her goals
based on your previous decade what would
you say okay so the next decade I think
I want to spend I want to spend a bit
more time with with my wife and with my
kids I know I know that they're both
young
I've been married now five years but I
think that's something that's really
important because it used to be earlier
when you have time on holiday vacation
you actually do come with genius ideas
and so rather than working hard I want
to work really smart I want to be over
the next decade I'm gonna be way more
open to collaboration ideas I was a
little bit of like a lone ranger the
last decade I mean dude kind of a lot of
stuff myself now much more open to
collaborations more open-minded rather
than just like this is my thing and I am
doing this and I'm doing it all alone
it's like now man I'm open I'm gonna be
smart I'm gonna be spending time with my
family more I also I also watched even
this year not this decade this year I'm
gonna get in shape because I think that
I cave right now and I'm 28
I have a lot of energy and people say
that to me you got so much energy when
I'm 40 I want to have the same energy
and I know that if I am NOT in good
shape it's that there's gonna come a
time where it's gonna be like actually
this is I have the same energy I used to
have so I want to I want to I want to I
want to continue to have the same energy
so this year I'm gonna get in shape and
I've hired a full-time personal trainer
that literally just travels with me
trains me feeds me you know just hold me
to account environment is stronger than
well power as you always say and having
having Marvin who's my PT who's awesome
he's got like his own TV channel and
Skywarn he's almost like a bit of a
celebrity in the fitness space having
him with me just always constantly with
me he's not with me 24/7 but he's a seam
all the time having that environment is
amazing so we've literally just got
started this month and I'm learning yes
I'm excited about my health I'm excited
about my family I'm excited about
becoming a millionaire
I'm excited about inspiring and helping
a lot of people to make money and I'm
also excited about collaborating with
people and just having fun awesome is
probably a bit of a lesson for me that
what you just said because there was
once an article that Arianna Huffington
wrote and she said and there's kind of a
things this family friends business
health and sleep and you said choose 3
choose 3 and you can normally do 3 very
very well and there's gonna be some
level of compromise on the other two so
let's give you example if you're gonna
go push hard of business you're gonna
spend time with your family and for
instance you want to exercise you
probably gonna have to come
a little bit on sleep and you may not
see your friends as much as you want you
know but I've been saying that's so
often that I actually thought to myself
the other day I wonder if it's not
becoming a self-fulfilling prophecy in
that like why can't I have one yeah I
don't agree with yeah I why can't I have
nor five and I mean it's just the other
day I said to myself well if I keep on
saying that can I only have three which
are the five that you thought you have I
always thought that business I'm sure I
love business I love with doing what I'm
doing family and in some way shape or
form I really like my sleep so I was
like in some way shape or form I have to
choose between sleep and after choose
between sleep and exercise yeah that was
kind of my big compromise other a young
baby now my one's a better list it's
funny because when I met you when we
spent some time together training oh I
was jealous of your of your fitness the
omen B he took you top off at the train
the trainer program and I was like damn
like your energy and I came up to I said
like dude what do you eat man by but for
me it's always been a bit of an excuse
exact same reason I've always thought I
was so good in business yeah and for me
the five things would also be different
I'd also included faith in them as well
yeah I think that it's really important
to be close connected to God for me
that's a really important thing and I
know it's for you yeah we've spoken
about that with a lot of my travel I
used to do was on Sundays and and it was
it was a challenge for me and as we say
environment is stronger than willpower
even that journey for me being at home
on Sundays was a big part was a big part
of my priorities because I got to grow
closer my faith because of that you know
I know it doesn't have to be that way
but just for me there was a help yeah
but I think for me I've always said my
faith is strong my family actually when
my family is good
my money's good and business is good my
significance and my my recreational my
mission is good my health and fitness
and food and stuff that's not too good
but hey at least everything else is good
you know but I don't believe that
anymore now that you can literally have
it all because I see other people making
the excuse me saying well I've got I've
got a good rip my family and I enjoyed
this and and all that but yeah my
money's not too good but you know it
doesn't matter cuz I'd rather be happy
I'm like oh yeah you'd have to say I'd
rather be happy than how
both well I always say that you should
be I'm always very wary of some of the
talked too much about balance and all
quality of life and I'll tell you why
it's normally on the I believe those
things are important but often the mr.
message is coming from a messenger
that's often trying to justify their
current Lots so often they will justify
let's say their financial position by
saying well I just like to focus on
quality of life not money yeah oh I like
to focus on balance not money it's the
same thing as the same well why can't
you have if you're going to work hard
anyway yeah why don't you why can't you
have both oh I don't believe him in
work-life balance I think work working
for me is life I'm working I don't see I
don't understand how you can make a
distinction like when you can just turn
it off no when I'm working I'm not
really living yeah do you work to live
or do you live to work okay it's a
stupid question I'm excited about work
like and my wife boys jokes if I'm
reading a book she by extension reads
the whole book with me because every
single day at the dinner table and
people like don't talk about businesses
in example but like for me I'm just
talking about my exciting lesson I
learned from the book which is a laugh
less and most the time not a business
listen I'll be like oh you baby won't
believe what I learned today in this
book there my wife always joke and say
she's read all the books with me because
I'm just excited about it it's not that
I bring work into personal life it's
just it's just I'm excited about you
know so um anyway listen I'm excited for
2020 I'm excited to impact a lot of
lives and I think you know there's
really so many people doing well in
property I think that 2020 is going to
be a a really decisive year for not only
us personally but also by extension of
that I truly believe that there's one of
my greatest books I've ever read is a
book by the name of lead the field by
illa nightingale and he said the person
that makes the most money is simply the
person that serves the most and I really
excited in that journey with you and to
have seen how how focused you aren't
serving first and I and I have to really
commend you here one of the big focuses
for me in 2020
when it comes to business has been
actually just did a podcast on this
myself was how content content and
information is really the gateway if you
will towards helping people grow and
putting as much as that out on the
internet for free and as when I commend
you for the lives you've changed just by
doing that man I don't know anyone that
invests the amount of money that you do
and the time you do and etc into doing
what we're doing now and changing
people's lives of that so look for two
amazing 22 anyway thanks man and also
yourself you know you are a massive
inspiration to me a great friend if
people want to check you as well you you
you you you even speak out and we run a
lot of the crash course yeah with me
alongside me and also you even running
one this weekend on your own which we
are we this weekend we're but on 750
people coming down to Ibis I'll be there
I'll be in the audience watching nice so
people will be like I'm coming to the
property investors crash goes by Samuel
Leeds Samuel Leeds is going to be sat in
the audience with me but did you know
what there's very few people on the
planet that I would let teach my
programs like that but not only if
you've been there done it got the
t-shirt you're a multi-millionaire
you've you know property really well
you're all so amazing communicator but
you've got the same mission that I have
so if people were listening to this and
they want to see more variety I want to
see more of me
get down booked on to the property
investors crash course awesome see you
guys soon I hope you enjoyed the podcast
and we'll do a lot more of these in the
future
[Music]
you
[Music]